this is a really i'm glad he um direct
messaged me because the guest that we
have today
is this is the perfect guy to just have
this topic
around because i have to say this many
many many many many many many many years
ago
i saw this dude and um i didn't trust
him
i was scared of him you know i mean
because i was a huge fan of jackass yeah
you know i was a huge fan
of what they did as a unit but this dude
was like a walking meth scab
i mean i was yeah it was
bro he'd be around i'd be like i gotta
walk the other way i mean
anything could happen okay right i
remember seeing them
at the mint they were at the mint and
they were doing
a jackass live thing i think we man was
there you were there right
and they were stapling their [ __ ] nut
sex their thighs
i left 10 minutes into it i thought it
was some sort of demon
demonology convention technology
convention demonology convention
i was so scared right but i have to say
this and listen to me right now
and this is the truth and i'm not i'm
not gonna mince words here
this is not funny this is real okay
so you know i had been sober since i was
17 years old
right and i you know and then i relapsed
everyone knows my story at
when i was 31 or 32 then i
stayed sober for another 17 years and i
think all the
you know when you're sober for a very
long time in your head you you start
kind of going
is it real you know does it does
12-step groups work that you know i mean
am i a part of a
cult what is going on here am i you know
and i have to say you said i could say
whatever i want to but you know
you know you and i did a i i don't want
to bring this up because it's a little
embarrassing for you but we you and i
did a
okay you and i did it you and i did a um
we were i think we were in vegas do you
remember that
okay all right all right well you know
what so that you can talk i'm just gonna
say your name so you can talk
steve oh give him a round of applause
evo all right yeah
dude yeah do you remember that i do man
yeah i was in i was a pile i remember
uh it was a video game award yeah
something like that yeah award show yeah
vegas and uh as with the word shows
you've got the
the rehearsal right they run through it
and i showed up to this rehearsal
and they just kicked me out it was you
and i were supposed to
present an award together so it was you
and i together shoulder shoulder on the
stage
yeah yeah and i was just in a state i
was i was
drunk i hadn't slept for for maybe days
i was
i was utterly intoxicated and i don't
even know on how many substances
and they kicked me the hell out of there
and you had i i had to do it by myself
you know that
i'm sure that you did i'm sure you were
you were thrilled to do it by yourself
after what a meth scab is
was a [ __ ] mess that's a great way to
put it i was a real meth scab that day
yeah i i remember
we're up there rehearsing i think with
samuel jackson was hosting it
yeah yeah yeah you yelled something at
him oh yeah yeah
i think you yelled why are you doing
this you're a movie star
you go you're a movie star why are you
doing this you're a sellout
and then all of a sudden i see security
people
drag stuff away from the stage
right and i'm and then this is what i
distinctly remember
it was brian poussin and pat and oswald
were in the audience because they were
next or whatever and i remember looking
at brian
hussein and pat oswald and they both
simultaneously went we're so
sorry right and then
you you left and i'm like what the [ __ ]
just happened
and then i heard you were like bad i
mean you're probably not anymore but you
were banned from the casino right
oh man i'm sure i'm banned from plenty
because
yeah yeah so anyway so now cut to that
experience i have with him
and then you know and then um i remember
i heard that steve got sober
and you know and when people when you
hear that you go uh
is that you know maybe it won't work
because you can be fair
most of the time it does not work it's a
large majority
of alcoholics and addicts that never
achieve long-term sobriety
right they only have a 15 this is what i
heard
you know um recovery rate or whatever i
think it's like less like five
i've heard it's more like five oh really
i heard yeah well i i [ __ ] highballed
it huh
yeah yeah so five percent so yeah you
know knowing that
you know i you know been around a long
time in sobriety i thought
it's gonna be a fleeting thing let's
pray that he gets it
it's it's like a phoenix bro this guy
transformed he he literally put
so much more energy into my
sobriety because in my head i'm like
dude it does [ __ ] work
because to see the change within this
man
you're a completely different guy you
really are i mean
i mean you're almost like two goodie
two-shoes for me man
well i don't know about that yeah
i mean you became a vegan right are you
still vegan ah no i'm
back on the fish oh you're back on the
fizz yeah other than fish i haven't had
any meat for
over 12 years wow yeah and i think one
year you looked at me and you go
yeah man uh i'm done with sex for a
while
uh-huh for how long um i did not blow a
load for the entire year of
2014. wow oh my god
imagine i was completely celibate
no wow